In this lecture I'm going to discuss
liquidated damages and agreed remedies and
then we'll look at the cell
phone termination fee cases
from California in 2011
one underlying principle we have seen
throughout this course is a strong
preference in contract law to compensate
the plaintiff instead of to punish the
defendant. That's why, uh,
there are severe limitations on
punitive damages in contract cases.
It's also why we've seen the courts are
reluctant to enforce conditions that
work forfeitures on defendants.
The same tendency can be seen when a
contract involves liquidated damages.
That is when a contract
contains a provision setting
out what the damages should
be for particular types of breaches.
If liquidated damages serve as a
quote penalty or forfeiture clause,
courts will not enforce them considering
them to be unconscionable or against
public policy.
A clause which liquidates damages at an
unreasonably high amount is sometimes
referred to as an interim clause.
These pound of flesh provisions are not
enforced because they placed the promise
or in terror or fear that she may not be
able to perform a standard formulation
of the rule.
Concerning enforceability appears in
judge Kaufman's opinion from a case called
leasing services
corporation versus justice,
which found that liquidated
damages are enforceable.
Only quote,
if the amount liquidated
bears a reasonable proportion
to the probable loss and
the amount of actual loss is incapable
or difficult of precise estimation.
These liquidated damage provisions
will not be enforced if they are quote
plainly or grossly disproportionate
to the probable loss unquote.
These criteria are often met in situations
where a company has many individual
contracts of the same type and it
knows it's average loss per breach,
but it's hard for the company to
determine the exact number of lost dollars
corresponding to each
particular breach of contract.
Section two seven 18 of the uniform
commercial code incorporates these same
principles.
As you can see,
the amount of the damage has to be
quote reasonable in the light of the
anticipated or actual harm.
They can not be unreasonably large.
They also must be justified
by the difficulties of
proof of loss corresponding
to the idea that the actual loss from
the breach of a particular contract must
be difficult to calculate.
The second restatement section on
liquidated damages is quite similar.
The economists have severely critiqued
the doctrine on liquidated damages.
The doctrine refusing to enforce
many of these provisions.
The economists arguments fall
into three main categories.
The first argument is that
parties are rational, uh,
in bargaining for a contract.
They negotiate many provisions but
ultimately signed the contract.
If it's to their advantage, if parties
sign a liquidated damage provision,
they must've gotten something else
at least as valuable and exchange.
And so we should generally,
uh,
enforce contracts that will
tend to make parties better off.
The next and related argument is that
the parties know more about the value of
losses they incur. If there's
a breach, then the court does,
they should be allowed to set and
liquidated damages based on that private
knowledge without the court coming in
later to second guess their decision.
And finally,
the doctrine on liquidated damages
prevent the parties from shifting risk.
For example,
if parties set liquidated damages for
a seller's breach to be more than the
buyer's cost for covering transaction,
that prevents the seller from getting
all of the upside risk of a better
opportunity.
Coming along.
The liquidated damages clause gives the
buyer a bargaining chip to negotiate for
part of the game.
Under the current doctrine.
It would be much more difficult to
shift any upside risk to the buyer.
For these reasons,
economists have suggested that courts
should simply enforce liquidated damage
provisions as written unless there's
a procedural reason to think that the
parties did not consent.
You might still strike down clauses
that were procedurally as well as
substantively unconscionable,
but you wouldn't strike them down merely
because courts felt one side was buying
too much.
Insurance state courts have varied in
the extent to which they've engaged with
these economic arguments with some
being more willing to enforce liquidated
damage provisions than others.
This should not give you the sense that
parties have no ability to contract
about the results of the suit for
breach of contract parties may generally
specify what sorts of
remedies will be available.
Section two seven 19 of the UCC sets
out one version of of this kind of
regulation.
It allows parties to set out
additional remedies beyond those.
The UCC generally makes available or to
substitute their own preferred remedies.
For the UCC is remedies under sub
section three of this prevention which is
emitted from this slide. They can
even disallow consequential damages.
Subsection two however,
ensures that the non breaching party will
always have enough effective remedy if
the substitute remedy quote
fails of its essential purpose,
the general UCC remedies spring back
into life and are available as a fallback
option.
Let's look at one case dealing with a
kind of liquidated damage provision,
a kind that to which many of you have
been subject the cell phone termination
fee cases from California in 2011 dealt
with early termination fees charged by
sprint to customers who end their cell
phone service contract before the term is
up.
These pictures should give you a quick
reminder of what cell phones looked like
back when this case was decided
back in the 1990 sprint found that it
had excessive churn and it's cell phone
customers.
That means too many customers were backing
out of their contracts and going with
other providers.
In 2000 it introduced an early termination
fee of $150 and saw a significant
decrease in churn in 2005 it increased
the termination fees to $200 over the
period covered by this case,
which is a class action on behalf
of California sprint customers.
It managed to collect nearly $74 million
in early termination fees from just
it's California customers.
The trial court found the
early termination fee to be
an unlawful penalty and so
it enjoined sprint from continuing to
collect it and awarded damages of the full
amount collected.
But the jury had also found that
the actual damages to sprint,
we're more than $225 million equal to
the amount of unpaid early termination
fees,
which indicated that they had
misunderstood the question
and the testimony and
so the court ordered a partial new trial
on the question on that question and on
how to set off those damages
against the amount collected.
Both parties appealed.
We are now reading justice a brony
errors opinion from the first district
California Court of Appeals. He considered
the question of whether sprints,
early termination fees acted
as invalid liquidated damages.
The court applied a two part test to
determine whether the early termination
fees served as a penalty and
was therefore unenforceable.
These this two part test is similar to
the statement we saw earlier by Judge
Kaufman but is not quite identical.
The first part should look familiar.
It must be impracticable or extremely
difficult to determine the amount of
damages here.
The trial court had found that it was
very difficult to calculate sprints,
avoidable costs from any
given a termination and so
sprint pass this first test
and the plaintiffs didn't dispute
that sprint failed. The second prong.
However,
this required not merely as
judge Kaufman and the UCC had it,
that liquidated damages be reasonable.
Rather,
the amount of the damages must have
been set by a reasonable endeavor to
determine what is fair
compensation for the loss.
It's not enough that the
amount be reasonable,
but the process to reach that amount
must have been based on an estimation of
actual damages.
Here sprint failed.
It's set the amount with an eye toward
reducing churn by imposing penalties on
customers who left,
not with an eye toward compensating
it itself or their loss business.
This result doesn't seem entirely fair.
Based on the court's
discussion of the facts,
it seems quite likely that sprints,
actual losses may have been larger
than the amount of assessed in early
termination fees should it
really be prevented from
recouping it's actual losses
because it used an improper process to
set liquidated damages that turned out to
be too low. In any event,
that is how the court rule
sprint tried to argue that it's fees.
We're not a penalty,
but rather an alternative
mode of performance. Uh,
under sprints theory,
customers may fulfill their obligation
either by sticking with their phone plan
or by paying the fee as an
alternative performance,
but the court didn't buy this argument.
They found that the contract allowed
sprint to impose the fee in voluntarily on
customers to pay the fee when sprint
decided to terminate their contracts,
when the customer's
failed to pay their bills,
which meant that the feed
behaved much more like a penalty.
Then an alternative performance that
the customers themselves could choose
justice.
Bruni air would not allow sprint to
quote indirectly accomplish in this way
something that the legislature
intended to prohibit.
Okay.
All right. Well, let's go to a quiz.
Sheila runs a rental car company and
customers often return cars late,
which often hurts her business because
she has no car available for the next
customer.
She knows that these losses loses her on
average $100,000 per year and that 500
cars are returned late each year.
What would be an acceptable amount for
liquidated damages for a late return?
Well, Sheila can probably
set liquidated damages, uh,
of at $200 and have them be enforced.
This is a situation where it is hard to
estimate exactly what the cost is for
many given late car because
of the individual rental
cars aren't associated with
particular customers in advance.
$200 quote bear is a reasonable proportion
to the probable loss unquote because
it's equal to the aggregate
loss of $100,000 divided
by the number of incidents
that contribute to that loss,
which is 500 that is a late
return on average cost Sheila,
$200 but it's difficult to say which
late returns because precisely what
proportion of those
losses in this lecture,
we've seen that liquidated damages clauses
set the amount of damages for breach
in advance and an explicit provision of
the contract courts will enforce them
when they satisfy two main criteria.
First,
they must be reasonably related
to the amount of actual losses.
And in California they must actually
be set based on such a calculation.
Second, it must be difficult
to calculate the actual losses.
So the setting of liquidated damages
in advance serves a useful function.
But also keep in mind the
economic critiques we saw,
which suggests that even penalties
should be enforced as long as they are
adequately disclosed.